[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
russia warned that it would attack the
nato resupply routes and that is what
they did
a barrage of missiles struck the
military base just before 4 am on sunday
morning
this base has been a hub for some of the
weapons that have been brought in from
europe and a center to train foreign
fighters joining the conflict
we don't know if any of them were killed
driving towards the scene we passed
ambulance after ambulance coming the
other way
rushing the wound into hospital
it seemed quite likely to us that the
death toll would be far higher than
first reported
as we reached a village close to the
base the air raid sirens sounded again
[Music]
sending people running for the shelters
after the strikes overnight they were
visibly frightened the russians were
coming for them again
the wounded were taken to a nearby
hospital
we watched as more and more arrive
throughout the morning some with serious
injuries to their heads and limbs
by lunchtime the hospital was full
ambulances queued outside to take the
wounded elsewhere
this soldier told me that the first
missile struck before the warning signs
had even gone off it was like hell he
said
many of the wounded asked us not to film
their faces their families have fled to
europe whilst they've stayed behind to
help and they understandably don't want
them to see what's happened
it is too early to know whether this is
a new front in the war
or just a one-off attack
either way no one here or in nato's
capitals will sleep easy tonight
aleister bunkel sky news in western
ukraine